bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce mercredi 7 octobre
octobre rose justement est lancée le
mois d'octobre et comme chaque année
consacrée à la sensibilisation au cancer
du sein dans les yvelines le centre
régional de coordination des dépistages
des cancers propose des dépistages
gratuits aux femmes de plus de 50 ans
notre invité maurice brun président du
conseil départemental de la ligue contre
le cancer sera avec nous pour parler de
7 octobre rose 2020 dans un contexte de
crise sanitaire
la crise sanitaire justement a aussi
touché le tourisme
cet été une saison au ralenti et des
inquiétudes pour l'arrière saison
l'exemple du château de versailles dans
l'actualité également le gymnase du
moulin à vent de coignières vient de
rouvrir ses portes
rénové et colorée associations sportives
et culturelles peuvent à nouveau
profiter de cet équipement est aussi
voici la suite de notre dossier
véronique matillon maire divers-droite
de rambouillet on fera son portrait
comme je vous le disais en titre octobre
rose est lancé jusqu'au 31 octobre
depuis une dizaine d'années le centre
régional de coordination des dépistages
des cancers accompagne les femmes dans
les yvelines quarante mille dépistages
du cancer du sein chaque année dans ce
centre yvelinois les précisions d'astrid
bergère et de michael et demi d'euros
depuis 2004 le dépistage organisé du
cancer du sein a été généralisé dans les
yvelines quarante mille dépistages ont
lieu tous les ans grâce à cette antenne
du centre régional de coordination des
dépistages des cancers
un service public qui accompagne les
femmes dès l'âge de 50 ans donc on
reçoit notre les femmes reçoivent notre
invitation
elles prennent rendez-vous dans un
centre de radiologie donc nous on
adresse avec l'invitation une liste de
radiologue agréé au dépistage organisé
et les femmes vont passer donc tous les
deux ans si tout se passe bien
une mammographie de dépistage organisé
jusqu'à l'âge de 74 ans
les centres de coordination des
dépistages des cancers est aussi là pour
contrôler une deuxième fois les
résultats des mammographies on reçoit
les mammographies après que les femmes
aient répondu à nos invitations de
dépistage organisé et est passé dans un
premier temps leur mammographie dans un
centre de radiologie du département où
d'ailleurs partir du moment où ils ont
été considérés normal par le premier
lecteur dans le centre d'imagerie elles
viennent à la structure de gestion pour
être lue par un second radiologue avant
d'être retournés aux femmes avec la
conclusion finale
la dizaine de personnes qui travaillent
dans cette structure accompagne donc les
femmes pendant tout le processus de la
sensibilisation de l'importance du
dépistage jusqu'au résultat
au total 250 femmes sont dépistées
positives au cancer du sein chaque année
dans les yvelines
grâce au dépistage généralisé et nous
accueillons maurice brun à ce sujet vous
êtes le président du comité des yvelines
de la ligue contre concert bonsoir et
bienvenue
bonsoir vous êtes avec nous pour parler
justement de ce mois de sensibilisation
qu'on nomme octobre rose
j'imagine que cette année l'opération
est un tout petit peu quand même
particulière avec la crise yannick
alors bien évidemment c'est une star
comme dirait ce tous les ans on a le
défilé de toutes les manifestations qui
ont lieu toutes les associations et les
commerçants qui s'associe à octobre rose
bien évidemment cette année c'est un
petit peu perturbé nous avons eu pas mal
de réservations de contact pour des
animations qui ont été annulés et puis
et puis peut-être que c'est là aussi la
le fait qu'il ya eu des élections
municipales
il y aura certainement de deux
municipalités qui nous ont contactés
tardivement pour remettre sur place qu
un certain nombre d'activités
donc si vous voulez l'un dans l'autre ça
va quand même un mois assez chargé pour
nous et du coup on a entendu dans le
reportage quarante mille dépistages dans
les yvelines
chaque année est ce que ce chiffre est
est suffisant pour le département alors
il faut savoir que pour ce département
comme pour tous les départements de
france on en reste quand même qu'à un
petit 50 % de personnes qui vont
s'adonner au test de dépistage organisé
il faut tempérer ce chiffre en disant
qu'effectivement il comme un certain
nombre de gens qui feront la démarche
individuellement
donc si vous voulez la statistique
globale s'établit aux alentours de 105
110 % néanmoins néanmoins comme un
certain nombre de gens qui passent à
travers le dépistage et c est vraiment
exactement contre cela que l'on lutte et
que l'on essaie absolument de d'amener
chacune chacune des femmes dans la
tranche d'âge et même peut-être avons
quelquefois à les voir aller voir son
généraliste aller voir un spécialiste x
est nécessaire et surtout aller au
dépistage est justement quelle est
l'importance de ce dépistage
et bien si vous voulez si on considère
que le cancer du sein c'est un cancer
contrôle plutôt bien ça reste quand même
un petit scandale de constater que douze
mille personnes meurent tous les ans de
ce cancer concerne plutôt bien une
personne soit une femme sur huit sera
touchée par ce cancer et 12000 parents
vont en décider si catastrophique pour
nous pour nous bien évidemment quel que
soit le
le nombre de gens qui se font dépister
ce n'est jamais assez
et est-ce que du coup le fait de
répondre à ces douze mille femmes qui
décèdent chaque année c'est le chiffre
que vous venez d'annoncer est ce que le
dépistage précoce pourrait être plutôt
bénéfique pour essayer d'endiguer ce
nombre assez assez énorme en effet bien
évidemment on dit toujours qu un cancer
dépisté tôt et c'est exactement le but
du dépistage dépister tôt à lorsqu'il
n'y a pas de symptôme un cancer mais
très longtemps se développer quand on
envoie les traces quelques voix c'est un
peu trop tard et donc là justement à
mener toutes les femmes qui
effectivement non pas de doute sur leur
santé mais vont néanmoins ses bras
dépistage s'est trouvé peut-être des
cancers naissant invisible impalpable et
et serait économisé une grande partie de
sa vie
alors comment se fait dépister qu'est
comment peut-on dresseur dépister et
puis à partir de quand doit-on le faire
on parle le dépistage précoce de plus de
50 ans est ce qu'il ya un âge entre
guillemets disons que le dépistage
organisé ces 50 74 ans c'est le siège
cdc dont vous venez de parler qui
justement fait les convocations fait les
relances etc et qui essaye de
sensibiliser chacune des personnes
maintenant on voit de plus en plus de
femmes qui sont touchées par le cancer
du sein
bien avant c'est à de 50 ans et je
dirais même malheureusement de plus en
plus donc si vous voulez à partir de 25
ans par exemple on peut conseiller à
toutes les femmes d'aller voir son
généraliste d'aller voir son gynécologue
éventuellement et de se faire palper des
simples pour une première détection
éventuel s'il ya un doute il y aura une
graphie derrière ce ne sera peut-être
pas forcément nécessaire mais si vous
voulez si cette précaution était déjà
respectée on éviterait beaucoup bien des
déboires ultérieurement
parce que encore une fois je le redis
parce que c'est très important on voit
de plus en plus de jeunes femmes
touchées par le cancer du sein est tout
à l'heure vous me disiez qu'il avait
donc douze mille décès chaque année du
cancer du sein est ce qu'on peut en
guérir et qu'elle en ait un petit peu le
traitement alors s'il ya douze mille
décès ya quand même une cinquantaine de
milliers de gens
qui déclare ce cancer donc c'est vous
montrer que quand même sur sur les 12000
ça fait quand même une très grosse très
grosse chance de succès c'est ce qu'il
faut dire c'est un cancer qui sonne
plutôt bien donc trop bête c'est trop
bête comme je divulguais remet en excuse
moi mais c'est trop bête de mourir d'un
cancer qu'on dépiste facilement et qu'on
traite facilement
voilà c'est un petit peu ce qui nous à
la ligue nous nous fait un peu sortir de
nos gonds c'est de constater que c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut vaincre et que
malheureusement par négligence parfois
et bien c'est enfin accorder une bartelt
aussi importante
et justement pour revenir sur la crise
sanitaire est-ce que vous en tant que de
cancer les contre le cancer
excusez moi cette année vous avez été
encore plus attentifs dans le suivi des
patients atteints d'un cancer que ce
soit le cancer du sein d'ailleurs ou ou
n'importe quel autre cancer
alors il est bien évident que cette
année avec le confinement puis la
saturation des services hospitaliers ou
médicaux il est bien évident qu'il ya
énormément de dépisteurs qui n'ont pas
pu avoir lieu
ils se sont même arrêter complètement
qu'en lan plusieurs mois et il y à aussi
effectivement quelquefois même des soins
qui n'ont pas pu se faire pour les gens
qui font du a touché donc c'est vrai que
cette année on a eu un séisme si j'ose
dire qu'ils fassent se traduire
certainement tous les ans enfin dans les
années qui viennent vraisemblablement
par des retards de traitement retard de
dépistage par une mortalité accrue sas
et on s'y attend 150 milliards par an
150 mille morts par an quatre cent mille
nouveaux cas de cancer par an c'est ici
c'est catastrophique
et ça ne cesse d'augmenter donc on l'a
bien compris un l'important c'est de se
faire dépister ça le message est clair
merci
maurice brun d'avoir été avec nous pour
ce journal et merci pour toutes ces
précisions
merci à vous
la crise sanitaire a commencé mi des
difficultés également dans l'économie
notamment la filière du tourisme dans
les yvelines une saison estivale au
ralenti plus de touristes étrangers et
des inquiétudes qui perdure l'arrière
saison quant à elles restent floues
l'exemple du château de versailles avec
astrid bergère des visiteurs étrangers
qui manque cruellement avec la coved 19
le château de versailles a perdu 80% de
son public
on a ouvert en juin en essayant d'ouvrir
le plus tôt possible après 83 jours de
fermeture les faits les étrangers
n'étaient plus là c'est une certitude
mais on a eu en juillet août notamment
une population de visiteurs français un
peu plus louches plus que ce qu'on
attendait au fond les français qui sont
peut-être pas beaucoup partis en
vacances on prend en plus profiter du
château malgré ces touristes français le
château enregistre un déficit d'environ
35 millions d'euros
pas de conséquences financières pour les
1000 salariés du site
mais pour les emplois indirects la
situation est différente on à 83
concessionnaires les concessionnaires
seront des primes de chiffre d'affaires
et eux donc mais des agents enfin des
employés au chômage partiel ou repousse
des recrutements donc les vraies
difficultés économiques
face aux pertes liées à la crise le
château devrait pouvoir compter sur le
plan de relance du gouvernement
87 millions d'euros sur deux ans seront
consacrés au site
mais l'été a permis d'accueillir une
clientèle différente tous les publics
peuvent trouver quelque chose de
différent à versailles et les plus
jeunes peuvent venir à versailles sans
s'ennuyer et en faisant des parcours qui
n'ont pas besoin d'être totalement
exhaustif on n'a pas besoin de rester
cinq heures pour visiter la totalité du
château dassault le château continue de
proposer ces expositions comme celle à
la salle du jeu de paume une période
estivale plutôt mitigé pour de nombreux
sites yvelinois si l'été a été quasi
normal à l'espace rambouillet le musée
d'archéologie nationale accuse une
baisse de fréquentation de 70%
c'est call of duty world of warcraft ou
encore heures stone l'éditeur de jeux
vidéo activision blizzard a annoncé la
fermeture de ses locaux en france
basé à versailles ce sont environ 250
salariés qui sont concernés la
suppression du site yvelinois intervient
dans le cadre d'un projet de
réorganisation selon la société
américaine
déjà début 2019 et malgré de très bons
résultats économiques
activision-blizzard avait annoncé le
licenciement de huit pour cent de son
effectif total dans le monde soit 800
personnes dont 134 salariés en france
aujourd'hui la multinationale américaine
justifie cette décision par la volonté
de s'adapter à une industrie numérique
en constante évolution et hautement
compétitive
une réunion du comité social et
économique devraient avoir lieu les 13
et 14 octobre
notre dossier nous a conduit à
rencontrer les maires du département
pour ce troisième portrait découvrez
véronique matillon la maire divers
droite de rambouillet à 57 ans elle
succède à marc robert et devient l'une
des seules femmes du département à être
dirigé une ville de plus de 25000
habitants
rencontre avec michael et demi d'euros
et justine brasier c'était le 28 juin
dernier véronique matillon candidat
divers droite devient maire de
rambouillet 46 84 % des suffrages
après avoir été en charge de la
commission petite enfance et adjointe au
maire aux scolaires et à la famille sur
les deux mandats précédents elle succède
à marc robert le maire sentant qu'il
avait soutenu je ne m'y attendais pas je
n'ai pas de carrière politique en vue ni
vraiment une mission que je prends avec
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'intérêt je
suis passionné par ce que je fais on me
l'avait dit et bien mes prédécesseurs me
l'avait dit et je confirme c'est
vraiment passionnant
après avoir été intronisé en juillet
dernier véronique mathieu on devient
officiellement la seconde femme maire de
la ville de rambouillet après jacqueline
tome patenôtre sur ce mandat dans les
yvelines elle est également l'une des
seule femme maire d'une ville de plus de
25000 habitants
j'estime que le fait d'être une femme
c'est un débat parce que je suis une
femme que je suis maire qu'on l'entende
bien je pense que ça prouve que en tant
que femme travaillant mère de famille eh
bien on peut réussir aussi à accéder à
ces postes pendant la semaine véronique
mathieu on se déplace sur le terrain
cela 10
octobre la nouvelle maire se rend dans
cette résidence pour seniors à
l'occasion de la semaine bleue les
venues participer à un déjeuner et à
l'auto c'est très important les seniors
pour moi c'est une génération qui a son
importance je suis infirmière en
gérontologie
donc c'est un public pour lequel j'ai
beaucoup d'affection
beaucoup datent h et je pense qu'il est
vraiment très important de leur montrer
à quel point nous avons besoin d'eux et
à quel point ils sont aussi toute
l'histoire de notre vie de notre ville
de notre pays
des rencontres qui s'organise dans des
semaines chargées pour la nouvelle élue
de 57 ans j'avais posé comme condition
de pouvoir continuer à travailler parce
que je suis très attaché à mon métier
d'infirmière en gérontologie
je travaille le lundi au réseau le mardi
de 9h à 17h ce qui me permet de venir en
mairie avant d'aller au bureau s'il le
faut et surtout de venir en mairie
après ma journée de travail c'est une
deuxième journée qui s'entame mais ça se
fait tout à fait bien ap la lune
millimétré la femme politique devra
faire avec pendant plusieurs années même
si elle veut vivre au jour le jour vers
une occupation ne refuse pas de se
représenter dans six ans lors des
prochaines municipales pour mener à bien
les différents projets de la commune
rénové et coloré le gymnase de
coignières s'est refait une beauté
depuis lundi 5 octobre l'équipement a pu
rouvrir ses portes pour accueillir les
associations sportives et culturelles
célia gars tsongo s'est rendu sur place
après neuf mois de rénovation le gymnase
de coignières a rouvert depuis lundi
seulement le rez-de-chaussée l'ouverture
de la mezzanine est prévue pour le 14
octobre après le passage de la
commission de sécurité
on avait besoin en effet de la
rénovation de cet équipement aujourd'hui
les premières associations qui ont
visité les lieux sont ravis un pour dire
on le serait à moins c'est c'est
vraiment une très très belle rénovation
la quinzaine d'enfants de l'association
l'école des sports a pu fouler en
premier le sol refait à neuf très
heureux depuis le temps qu'on attend
effectivement
il était très attendue par les
utilisateurs et on est content de
pouvoir ouvrir et les enfants en
priorité
déjà qu'ils s'amusent bien déjà sur le
nouveau terrain qui est coloré très
pratique
en plus des associations sportives les
écoles et les collèges pourront
également utiliser cet équipement
au total le montant des rénovations
atteint 2 millions 56 mille euros un
budget qui a servi à installer un mur
d'escaladé avec plusieurs niveaux de
difficulté une salle de fitness et un
ascenseur pour l'accessibilité des
personnes à mobilité réduite
on a refait intégralement les vestiaires
et les douches parce que ça ça
nécessitait on a refait le chauffage
intégralement
on a refait tout l'éclairage aujourd'hui
grâce à ces travaux qu'on a fait en
termes d'économie d'énergie
on va économiser à peu près 20%
d'énergie par rapport au gymnase
précédent donc c'est quand même là un
gain substantiel
les parents venus chercher leurs enfants
ce jour là ont pu constater les travaux
finis il est bien équipé
toutes les installations on a des supers
gymnase on peut faire du handball du
futsal peut vraiment bien bien profité
l'inauguration officielle du gymnase est
prévue autour du 12 décembre et les
poignets rien sont invités à visiter
l'équipement et c'était la nuit blanche
le week-end dernier à la commanderie de
saint quentin en yvelines
de 20h à minuit les visiteurs ont pu
rencontrer les artistes et admirer les
oeuvres présentées pour l'occasion au
programme sculpture exposition vidéo
spectacles ou encore oeuvres
interactives
retour sur l'événement avec justin
brasier nicolas landry la commanderie a
fait nul blanche ce week end
cette année l'événement et et
pluridisciplinaire mêlant dans ce
sciences et arts visuels objectifs de
l'événement faire découvrir à la
diversité de la création contemporaine
au programme quatre artistes étaient
présents pour présenter leurs oeuvres
c'est le cas de l'installation babel
composé de quinze mille tonnes la
thématique babel
donc fait référence fait écho surtout à
toutes les situations de crise qu'on
traverse actuellement et qui ont assez
sensible à ce sujet là j'ai voulu
vraiment mettre en lumière le fait
qu'aujourd'hui on peut tous parler la
même langue et très rapidement depuis ce
qu'on prend pendant la soirée la
compagnie le grand jeter a donné deux
représentations de son spectacle
réplique un spectacle qui casse le
traditionnel mur avec le public
c'est l'idée de de la pièce de jouer
avec le public de s'échanger d'avoir des
regards de l'inviter à la danse et du
coup de briser un peu ce quatrième mur
qui peut parfois rire sur scène
[Musique]
l'événement s'est déroulé à la
commanderie un lieu riche en histoire
qui inspiré les artistes et émerveillé
les visiteurs alors comment nous dansons
dans cet endroit historique avec notre
structure
ce site décor notre spectacle mais nous
nous fondons aussi dans le décor il ya
des choses auxquelles on rentre dans le
pas de deux valeurs meilleur des
artistes là où ils les prennent ils les
mettent en valeur pour transmettre des
messages derrière et vraiment c'est très
étonnant c'est magnifique
l'acrobatie j'ai vu l'inta j'avais
l'intérieur de la commanderie
j'ai vu un chat carton là bas au total
cinq projets artistiques étaient
présentés dans les différents lieux de
la commanderie
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi vous retrouverez le 7-8
journal demain à 18 heures présenté par
grégory canale mais avant cela vous
pourrez revoir toutes nos émissions sur
notre site internet tv soixante dix huit
points comme et sur notre application
mobile tv 78 et jusqu'ici je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée
[Musique]